Thanos was an idiot check this out if  Thanos really wanted to make sure that  his plan was going to work he would have  used the Infinity Stones to dust half  the universe's population then he would  have used the reality Stone to make sure  that the population of every world only  ever stated 50 meaning the only time a  child is born is when an older person  dies after that he would use the Mind  Stone to wipe the knowledge or memories  of everything that happened in Infinity  war from the minds of everybody who's  aware of it meaning no one would know  why half the universe's population  disappeared nobody would know why every  world's population only remains at 50  and they would never come looking for  Thanos meaning nobody would ever undo  what he did God I hope I never get  superpowers I'm a straight-up villain  and if I get powers y'all are scurred  make sure you follow for more